life for Lazarus kariza and his family
could become more unbearable he doesn't
have a job he can't afford to send all
his children to school and says he
hasn't got the 25 dollars needed to pay
rent
next Monday if I don't pay rent next
month the landlord will kick us out
where are we going to go I will still
need money to pay for rent wherever my
family goes
Zimbabwe's general election is on August
the 23rd the cost of living crisis is a
concern for voters several families are
struggling to cope in an economy with
one of the highest inflation rates in
the world selling on the street is the
easiest way
Council police officer Doug raids
rounding up vendors and confiscating
goods the government says the nation now
has enough food and that there are plans
to sell excess grain to other countries
but the cost of living crisis means many
families still need social assistance do
we have a number of households that are
crying out for food in particular areas
and despite us having the food in the
shelves in the supermarkets you may not
be able to to buy that same food and
this is where organizations like the wfp
comes in handy the cost of some basic
Commodities has come down a little bit
in recent weeks and government leaders
insist the economy is growing but for
many people here life is tough and some
zimbabweans say they're not just seeing
the economic turnaround they were
promised by politicians haramutasa Al
Jazeera Harare